one can wonder why does astronomy or any
sort of abstract pure research for that
matter make any difference to us to the
typical person in the world well first
of all thinking about the universe and
figuring out how things work is
something that of all animals only
humans can do only we have the intellect
the curiosity the opposable thumb with
which to build machines to explore
nature so some of us should do it
second of all these kinds of discoveries
discoveries about the cosmos excite kids
you know I like to say that astronomy is
the gateway science it gets kids
interested in science and technology
because they hear about all these
amazing discoveries I myself as a kid
was thrilled by the lunar landings of
the Apollo mission now most kids won't
go on into astrophysics but what they'll
do is they'll study science and
technology and they'll go into fields
that are more immediately useful to
society such as Applied Physics and
engineering and computer science and
medical physics but you know the bug
that bites them is oppan astronomy and
finally you never know what practical
spin-offs there might be and let me give
you a few examples a century ago when
quantum physicists such as Einstein and
Bohr and Heisenberg and Schrodinger
we're developing quantum physics they
had not the slightest practical
application in mind they didn't want to
make a better toaster or a better
bicycle or whatever they wanted to
understand the nature of light and why
atoms exist why atoms are stable and
other such questions of that sort that
seemed incredibly far removed from our
everyday lives will fast forward a
century you could not imagine today's
high-tech world without an understanding
of the micro physics the quantum world
look at the silicon revolution for
example look at lasers look at nearly
everything it all stems from quantum
physics
who would have thought that a century
ago another even perhaps more abstract
idea is Einstein's general theory of
relativity the theory that the presence
of mass or energy curves or warps the
shape of space and of time around it so
for example our Sun form the dimple in
space and earth moves along its natural
path through that dimple so two earth
forms a dimple and the moon moves along
its natural path through that warm space
that's what gravity is I Newton had a
formula for gravitational attraction but
he didn't know what it was and Einstein
came up with a theory well you might say
who cares as long as gravity works you
know what do we care what the exact
mechanism is well it turns out that
Einstein's theory makes predictions that
are in subtle ways different from
mutants predictions and for things like
the Global Positioning System GPS you
have to take the effects of general
relativity into account the clocks in
the satellites up in space these
satellites communicate with your device
in your car they run at a slightly
faster speed than the clocks here on
earth and if that difference in the rate
of passage of time had not been taken
into account by the physicists and
engineers who designed and built the GPS
system GPS wouldn't work so here's
something of incredible military and
commercial value that simply would not
work if we didn't understand gravity in
a fundamental way according to Einstein
this idea of curved space-time so again
who would have thought that a century
ago when Einstein was developing the
general theory of relativity that it
would have this incredible practical
application sure we might never get
close to a black hole which is an
extreme prediction of general relativity
but it doesn't matter
the theory was developed it's beautiful
it excites kids
and it even has practical applications
so with much of astronomy we don't know
what the spin-offs will be but we do
know that as humans we can accomplish
these goals and can also excite kids
into pursuing areas of science and
technology and that in my opinion is
really good
[Music]